by also stages cut off from the rest of
Nigeria and Fuel and Food Supplies have
stopped coming in
motorists are buying petrol from Street
vendors like ebi bierfa who are braving
the dangers of bringing in supplies from
other states we have to carry the work
alone inside we had to carry the fuel
and canoes and pay off militants along
the way even security personnel harasses
with only two petrol stations operating
in the capital business is good
the petrol stock in this station is old
but the price is not buyers here are
forced to pay nearly three times the
official price but they say they don't
mind as long as they can get enough to
be able to move around and to power
their electricity generators
the electricity here is cut off so
people are buying fuel
you have to fear your generator to be
able to know what is happening around
you you know the only thing you have we
are trying to do now is to stay safe
with you and your family
as field prices go up so do transport
costs
and Traders pass on the increases to
Consumers like gift Okafor whose return
to the market is stock up
but she finds food prizes have tripled
normally we
we take late in the morning and then
early in the evening then we go to bed
floods in Bayelsa State have displaced
more than a million people and many are
in camps
conditions are much better with food
supplies and shelter still inadequate
the government says it's shipping in
supplies from neighboring states
but many fear that may take days or even
weeks to reach them Ahmed Idris Al
Jazeera yenagoa